hey what's up everybody it's Warren and
now that the Avengers end game trailer
is finally out the Russo brothers have
been speaking out a little bit about it
in some interviews in a recent interview
the researchers talked about the
consequences stakes and the cost of
resurrecting the Fallen Heroes and
Avengers endgame do we all remember how
before Avengers infinity war came out we
all thought that a ton of our heroes
were going to die in the movie and I'm
not talking about from Thanos to snap
I'm talking about from Thanos actually
killing heroes physically in battle I
think a lot of people thought that some
main characters were going to die such
as Thor Captain America Iron Man The
Hulk Black Widow Hawkeye war machine but
they made it out alive
in fact Santos managed to gather all of
the Infinity stones and perform the snap
wiping out half of the universe from
existence but the main Avengers managed
to survive the snap what a coincidence
they're marvel
so our original Avengers are left with
some supporting characters as well but
there are a lot of characters that got
dusted due to the snap however I think
the majority of people believe that
these characters are going to be coming
back somehow and this kind of
disappointed fans due to the lack of
consequences and stakes and Marvel
movies but even still people believe
that either Captain America or Iron Man
are going to die in Avengers end game
and recently in some interviews the
Russo brothers commented on the fact
that Avengers in game is going to have
real stakes real consequences and will
be a tearjerker
here's what Anthony Russo had to say in
an interview about consequences and
stakes one thing that has always been
very important for Joe and I is a real
commitment to stakes and to consequences
we have the same commitment to the
stakes being real and things costing
characters in a real way so right off
the bat the Russo brothers acknowledge
that stakes and consequences are very
important to the movies and then they
confirm that there will in fact be real
stakes real consequences and things
costing characters in a real way in
avengers endgame but even though the
Russo brothers say that there will in
fact be real consequences and Avengers
in game we know that the heroes that
fell victim to the snap are going to
come back some
we have plenty of sequels coming in the
future that involved the dusted heroes
we have spider-man far from home coming
out we have black panther 2 guardians of
the galaxy 3 so we know that they're
coming back somehow but that does not
necessarily mean that there won't be
deaths permanent deaths and Avengers
endgame when talking about the
resurrection of the Fallen Heroes in
another interview here's what the Russo
brothers had to say Anthony started off
by saying I will say this there is a
real commitment on our end to the stakes
yes this is a fantasy world and yes
remarkable things can happen in a
fantasy world but and then Joe Russo
chimed in and said they come at an
incredibly high cost so basically what
is happening here is the Russo brothers
acknowledge that there are going to be
resurrections and Avengers in game
despite Thanos's clever line in the
beginning of Infinity Ward
[Music]
resurrections this time cuz like I just
said there's plenty of evidence that
some characters are coming back but just
because some characters are being
resurrected does not mean that there
still won't be some permanent deaths as
Joe Russo said in the interview some
things that they do in Avengers endgame
are going to come at incredibly high
costs Joe continued into interview by
saying for us there will always be
stakes and the stakes have been
progressing from film to film and I
think you can extrapolate that they will
continue to deepen in Avengers 4 so if
you take a look at all of the films in
the MCU that the Russo brothers have
directed you can definitely see that the
stakes have progressed over time in
Captain America the Winter Soldier
shield fell in Captain America Civil War
the Avengers fell apart and then in
Avengers infinity war they all lost
Thanos collected all the Infinity stones
and dusted away half of the universe so
the stakes and the consequences have
definitely progressed and they said that
they're going to progress even more in
Avengers endgame well the last
consequence was Santos wiping away half
of the universe from existence and we
know that they're coming back somehow so
how could consequences progress even
more in Avengers endgame permanent
deaths the Russo brothers have stated
that this is their movie they did it the
way they wanted to do it and it seems
like their way could involve killing
some characters and to top it off when
talking about deaths in the interview
Joe added with a sly smile just you wait
and when asked a fan should bring their
handkerchiefs to the movie Anthony Russo
said I will be bringing one so based off
of what Joe and Anthony Russo have said
in these interviews there will be stakes
there will be consequences and there
could possibly be permanent deaths and
Avengers in-game so let me know what you
think about what the Russo brothers said
in these interviews in the comments down
below do you think that these incredibly
high cost and these consequences are
going to mean some of our heroes are
going to die and if so who do you think
it's gonna be let me know what you all
think and I'm still giving away a
life-size Infinity Gauntlet if you would
like to interfere your chance to win all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thank you
all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you